elon musk the world's richest man by a
lot he's out here dropping dimes on
twitter he literally called out the un
food program after they posted an
absolutely insane statistic he's worth
about 300 billion dollars and he said
that he would immediately sell tesla's
stock if they could prove to him their
claim that six billion dollars would
solve world hunger the richest man in
the world said you're telling people
that it only would cost six billion
dollars to solve world hunger show me
your math and i will sell my stock right
now and i will give you six billion
dollars some may say elon musk called
out a six billion dollar bet
now two percent of his net worth would
be that six billion and in 2020 the
world food program raised 8.4 billion
dollars how come it didn't solve world
hunger well maybe because what we are
watching is the continued repeating of
asinine statistics
and
all sorts of really really really
absurd policies
everybody can rally around the idea that
no person on earth should be hungry and
everyone can rally around the fact that
folks want to help
but when you say things like if only
elon musk would give me six billion
dollars then i could solve world hunger
the internet is undefeated they go and
they check and last year you raised 8.4
billion so how come you didn't solve
world hunger if it only takes six
well
of course
elon he can't resist he just can't help
himself he said if you can describe on
this twitter thread exactly how six
billion dollars will solve world hunger
i will sell my tesla stock right now and
do it
but of course
we know how this game goes
david beasley whose twitter account is
the wfp chief because of course you need
everyone to know you're the chief
he said headline not accurate six
billion will not solve world hunger but
it will prevent geopolitical instability
mass migration and save 42 million
people on the brink of starvation an
unprecedented crisis and a perfect storm
due to covet conflict and climate
crisises elon musk with your help we can
bring hope build stability and change
the future let's talk it isn't as
complicated as falcon heavy but too much
at stake to not at least have a
conversation i can be on the next flight
to you throw me out if you don't like
what you hear now before we go on
if you're the world food program chief
and you're telling a guy hey this isn't
that as hard as falcon heavy if i'm the
guy who made falcon heavy heavy in my
team my first question is well it's not
as hard as what we already did why
haven't you solved the problem
because if the falcon heavy it's not
like it's some impossible test they
literally built it it's done like hey we
figured it out we did the science and
math we figured it out
so if the problem isn't as hard as
creating falcon heavy why is it not
solved maybe because again this is all
asinine commentary and so elon said i
don't need you to come fly to me just
publish your current and propose
spending in detail so people can see
exactly where money goes
sunlight is a wonderful thing
and so ladies and gentlemen this is what
the internet does
it ultimately is
judge jury and executioner whether you
think that's good or bad what we watched
was we watched a stupid headline that
had no basis in reality
get called out by the richest man in the
world publicly
and he called the bluff he said if six
billion dollars will solve world hunger
i'll sell my stock right now and give it
to you just prove to me how it does it
and then of course damage control comes
from the world food programs chief oh
the headline is not accurate of course
it will not solve world hunger but then
all of a sudden he goes but it will
prevent geopolitical instability mass
migration and save 42 million people on
the brink of starvation
geopolitical instability
but yet we can't actually solve world
hunger this is part of the problem is
that people always want to throw around
all these terms if you want to solve the
problem think of it from a first
principle standpoint and also if you
raised 8.4 billion dollars people should
know where that went and so that's what
elon eventually said
he said
show us i don't need you to fly to me i
don't want to have a private closed-door
meeting this is the internet people will
help you
just show your work
put it on the internet
be transparent tell us how you spent the
money previously and tell us what you're
gonna do with the money in the future
and my guess is if they had a legitimate
plan and it actually made sense to
intelligent people
elon musk would probably sell some stock
and give them a bunch of money maybe a
couple billion dollars and i bet there's
a bunch of other rich people who would
pitch in too
but what you end up finding is that some
of these organizations they do do some
good work but there's tons
of waste
8.4 billion dollars last year
where'd it go
what was the impact
how much good did they do
nobody knows
john when you saw elon musk tweeting
this
were you excited that he was engaging or
were you like oh here we go again i'm
very excited that he was engaging in
talks to end world hunger um i'm glad
that he was basically calling people out
on their bs talking about oh if you just
give two percent of your net worth you
could solve 100 he's like show me the
blueprint and we can do that and we can
move forward with that and i'll even
sell some stocks that i think will
appreciate because i work at the company
and i will sell it and we will do that
but then again comes back to it oh well
there's other technical that's not
really true he's calling people out on
their bs i love it um i think tesla
owners were shaking a little bit when he
was talking about selling some tesla
stock to end world hunger but good for
him and um i hope that he can help in
any way possible i think there's there's
two things to look at that are
fascinating one uh would be that the the
article was just
factually incorrect right and if you
read the quotes in the article the the
the head of the uh the world uh the
world hunger organization literally
didn't say anything like that like the
quote was just like 6 billion would help
save 42 million people it had nothing to
do with the full solving world hunger
and all that so they basically just uh
it was click bait they got caught etc
they updated it this morning now they
added the word would help solve world
hunger uh so that's one thing won't get
called out by anyone else it's fine
everyone moves on the other thing that's
fascinating i think is the idea that uh
i believe many other wealthy people
billionaires etc would be much more
willing to donate money
but they don't have control over their
current donations right they don't know
where a lot of this stuff is going they
can't facilitate it etc i think that you
have to remember that a lot of these
billionaires that are self-made
billionaires not people that inherited
their wealth but built businesses
they're world-class operators right
they're ceos of massive companies them
more than anyone else in the world know
how to efficiently allocate capital
right so when you think about an
organization the whole idea that i'm
going to give you six billion dollars i
want to see where that goes right i want
to make sure you're you're maximizing
that prof that money that i'm giving you
and distributing it efficiently and i
think open sourcing that process and
that data is an awesome solution i think
that's amazing and i think more people
should do that and i think uh elon musk
calling them out and saying i will do
that literally today if you can prove
that that's how you'll do it and you do
it in public and that's why one of uh
i'm a huge huge huge fan of what jack
dorsey has done with his donation he
donated i believe was a billion dollars
and he said i'm gonna put a billion
dollars and he's tracking it on a google
sheet right and he said everyone can
come look at exactly where i'm donating
money to what it's being used for etc
and i think that that's the way that a
lot of these donations are going to be
moving forward because if you want the
capital of the best uh operators in the
world people that know how to do this
for their own business you're going to
have to show and prove to them really
prove to them how it's being allocated
in a good way
how many people do you think work at the
world food program
total total number of people work with
them
local fifteen thousand a hundred
thousand
twenty thousand six hundred i guessed
over on purpose
eighty 87 of them are based in the field
that means 2
600 or so 2 700 are not based in the
field
that is 50 of twitter's employee base
yeah right and so when you start to look
at this they they their numbers off
their website 811 million people uh go
to bed hungry every night more than 10
of the world's population
and they said that after a nearly this
is a this is a real sentence a real
sentence
after nearly a decade of progress the
number of hungry people has slowly
increased
well you obviously didn't make progress
if the number increased
so
this is like the whole like corporate
nonsense you made zero progress if on a
net basis it increased so obviously
we're get it's getting worse rather than
getting better which is sad and we
should try to fix it but you have to be
realistic with yourself and say we
raised eight billion dollars last year
and the problem got worse
what's wrong what's happening is it just
a money thing or is there something else
and that's ultimately when you go and
you poke the bear when you go and you
poke somebody who literally for a living
does first principles thinking that's
what you get